después si hemos tenido dos semanas muy
complejas donde básicamente la ciudad y
todo el departamento de estado
bloqueados cambio la tercera ciudad de
colombia y el departamento del valle del
cauca donde nos ubicamos el tercer
departamento del país más o menos 5
millones de personas
pero además somos un gran abastecedor de
alimentos de medicamentos y de bienes de
higiene cuidado personal y del hogar a
colombia no solo porque tenemos pues una
gran potencia agroindustrial industrial
y productiva en la región sino también
porque aquí se ubica el principal puerto
del país de importación que es
buenaventura por una vez entra el trigo
la soya y el maíz alimentos para tanto
para animales como para humanos entre
otras cosas entonces pues nosotros éste
hicimos una encuesta en 1700 empresas de
todos los tamaños micro pequeñas
medianas grandes y estimamos que en
todos los sectores más o menos el 70% de
la producción está parada porque pues si
bien se puede más o menos circular
dentro de cali es ha sido ha habido para
cabellos bloqueos indefinidos
en las entradas a la ciudad y también
los municipios que nos rodean y en el
paso al puerto entonces pues nosotros
estimamos que eso nos cuesta en dos
semanas
un poco más de dos puntos del pib en dos
semanas algo así como 700 millones de
dólares es un impacto grande para
nuestra región y también para el país
porque somos grandes abastecedores de
que muchos vienen tener primera
necesidad ahora esteban en cuánto tiempo
es tema de ustedes que se pueden
recuperar de estas millonarias pérdidas
y qué tan cuesta arriba será esta
recuperación que además ya venía
afectada por la pandemia
pues lo más triste es que tuvimos
obviamente un año muy malo el año pasado
la economía colombiana cayó más de un 7%
la la pobreza se disparó el desempleo
igualmente en cali tuvimos uno de los
mayores aumentos de pobreza si bien
tenemos niveles en el valle y cary de
los más bajos de pobreza al país tuvimos
en cali el mayor aumento de pobreza el
año pasado sin embargo veníamos con una
dinámica bastante buena marzo el
desempleo había bajado considerablemente
y hoy pues no este año pues para
recuperar las pérdidas del año pasado
teníamos que crecer mucho no se estimaba
crecimiento para colombia en cinco de
seis con eso no recuperamos el terreno
perdido pero nos acercábamos a 2019 pues
ahora perdemos en dos semanas dos puntos
de ese crecimiento y esto pues claro
para las empresas es grave pero sobre
todo para los hogares hay gente pasando
hambre hemos perdido 89 mil personas se
han dejado de vacunar por los bloqueos
ahora las micros y medianas empresas
como se han visto afectadas durante el
conflicto en la ciudad de cali y como
ese panorama de la economía en el valle
del cauca las próximas semanas
pues mire no muy afectadas porque las
cadenas de suministro no están
funcionando entonces ha habido algo de
abastecimiento de gasolina y de
alimentos en unos medicamentos en los
últimos días pero las plantas fábricas
granjas bodegas que abastecen a cali y
en buena parte de nuestro país están
cerradas entonces estamos aliviando un
poquito el abastecimiento del momento a
pesar de que los ciudadanos pues no se
pueden mover con facilidad etcétera pero
vamos a tener un grave problema muy
pronto porque se están muriendo pues
gallinas ponedoras de huevos en pollos
cerdos las cosechas no se pueden recoger
y tenemos pues todo el aparato
industrial básicamente parado y de nuevo
esto es un mayor impacto
en el empobrecimiento y a veces 26%
lamentablemente las empresas que
encuestamos esos aunque ya están
reduciendo empleos
esteban gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted un feliz resto de día estamos
conversando con esteban piedrahita
presidente de la cámara de comercio de
cali para evaluar los costos que ha
tenido el paro en el departamento
el valle del cauca